dans les rues presque déserte on entend
que ça
tire son constant la ville emporte les
traces partout
et c'est surtout cet homme au sol
victime d'une explosion alors qu'il
roulait à bicyclette qui donne la mesure
où on se trouve
par Bluetooth est un champ de bataille
d'explosions mais ça le niveau de
décibel est trop élevé pour qui que ce
soit
Tatiana ne presse plus le pas malgré les
explosions elle s'en remettent à Dieu
il faudra beaucoup de temps avant que
ceux qui nous dirigent règle le centre
dit-elle russe et ukrainien nous allons
souffrir et c'est tout
après plusieurs heures des policiers
viennent enfin récupérer le corps de
celui qui restera aujourd'hui du moins
anonyme Vladimir vit juste à côté il a
vu la scène d'un mauvais œil des soldats
Ukrainiens sont passés plus tôt dit-il
sans chercher à lui porter secours
sont passés mais ils ne sont pas allés
vers l'homme mort il était peut-être en
vie Vladimir ne cache pas ses sympathie
pour la Russie
il y a des bombardements tous les jours
dit-il les ruines de l'usine sont juste
à côté ça vient des Ukrainiens
pourtant les soldats Ukrainiens sont
déployés de son côté à l'ouest de la
rivière qui sépare la ville de Dark
mouton 2
de tels propos feraient peur et Galina
de rage elle vient à la mairie dans
l'espoir de pouvoir recharger son
téléphone le seul lien qui lui reste
avec le monde extérieur comme tous les
résidents de la ville elle n'a plus
d'électricité d'eau ou de gaz pour faire
à manger
bien sûr nous avons beaucoup de traîtres
dit-elle vous croyez que toutes ces
explosions c'est simples vous savez si
j'étais plus jeune je joindrai les
rendre l'armée c'est vrai
Gabina est consciente que dans les
villes voisines du don-basse Vladimir
Poutine a ordonné des référendums pour
l'annexion à la Russie des territoires
que son pays contrôlent entièrement ou
en partie c'est un idiot
comment dire on dit qu'il est trop
ambitieux il veut tout mais il ne peut
pas tout avoir il dit qu'on fait partie
du monde russe son monde c'est une
utopie
ailleurs dans la région de kerki l'armée
russe battant retraite ou tente de
freiner l'avancée des Ukrainiens ici à
barthmoud les Russes redoublent des
formes et même une offensive pour
s'emparer du contrôle de la ville ce
serait pour la Russie une victoire
stratégique importante pour avancer plus
au nord et un baume sur la plaie d'une
série de défaites majeures
ce serait pour la Russie une victoire
stratégique importante pour avancer plus
au nord et un baume sur la plaie d'une
série de défaites majeures pour
l'instant l'armée ukrainienne arrive à
freiner l'offensive mais c'est soldats
en paix le prix les habitants se
demandent combien de temps tout ça va
durer
il n'y a rien de bon chez nous
déploreana la vie est vraiment mauvaise
nous voulons mourir Irina voudrait
lancer un puissant cri à la face du
monde mais elle n'en a plus la force
elle demande qu'on s'imagine être menacé
d'une attaque nucléaire au Canada
vivent tranquillement boivent mangent
tombent amoureux dorment paisiblement
nous n'avons pas ça et pour comprendre
il faut passer par là on ne sait pas
exactement combien des 75000 habitants
de barthout restent toujours dans la
ville peut-être 10 15000 c'est encore
beaucoup trop selon les autorités qui
voudraient bien évacuer tout le monde
avec l'intensification des pas et
l'hiver qui arrive
il y a bien de la distribution d'aide
pour ceux qui restent mais il
exploratiques à quelques 5 kilomètres de
barmouth dans le village de chassis
Viard on s'inquiète aussi de voir autant
de gens refusaient de partir malgré des
fratruses de plus en plus soutenues tous
les jours depuis une semaine ou cela
imprimero déplore des victimes
nous devons sauver notre peuple nous
voyons qu'ils sont victimes pas plus
tard qu'hier nous avons encore eu un
manche
les échanges de tirs sont souvent trop
intenses pour s'aventurer sur les routes
sinueuses et accidentées le groupe
Mozart composé d'anciens militaires
étrangers volontaires et souvent appelé
à la rescousse
une seule femme acceptera finalement de
partir elle laisse Victor son mari
derrière
nous avons peur bien sûr dit-il je ne
sais pas qui n'aurait pas peur tout le
monde a peur mais nous allons survivre
d'une manière ou d'une autre